اذا 300 يوم مضت على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا خسائر جمه اقتصاديه بشريه وخدميه
والفاتوره بازدياد ما عدم وضوح الرؤيه
لكيفيه انتهاء هذه الحرب السلطات
الاوكرانيه كشفت عن خسائر ودمار واسع لا
يمكن تعويضه كلفه باهظه لحرب مستمره مع
ظروف الشتاء القاسيه ليس على كاف فقط بل
على موسكو التي يرزح اقتصادها تحت العقبه
اطلقت روسيا
4,700 صاروخ على اوكرانيا وسببت بنشوب
16,000 حريق 97% من الاهداف التي
استهدفتها قوات موسكو مدنيه وفقا لوزاره
الخارجيه الاخرانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القصف الروسي تسبب ايضا في تدمير
1132 قطعه اثريه ثقافيه اضافه الى تدمير
2556 مؤسسه تعليميه بينما سجلت السلطات
الاوكرانيه تدمير او اتلاف 114 مرفقا
صحيحا نتيجه القذف الروسي مع التوثيق
لاربعه وخمسين الفا
و898 جريمه حرب عدوان
الروسيه التي تقول اوكرانيا انها تستهدف
المدنيين بشكل اوضح في قطع امدادات
الكهرباء والمياه بصوره متكرره في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وسط درجات
سامي
[موسيقى]
البنك الدولي منحه اوكرانيا 610 ملايين
دولار اضافيه لتمكينها خصوصا من تلبيه
الاحتجاجات الاكثر في مجال الصحه الدعم
هذا ياخذ شكل قردين من البنك الدولي
للانشاء والتعمير وهو جزء من مجموعه البنك
الدولي تضمنه خصوصا بريطانيا بسقف 500
مليون دولار الدعم من البنك الدولي يتيح
تغطيه نفقات الحكومه الاوكرانيه في مجال
الصحه ومساعده الاسر ودفع رواتب موظفي
الدوله وضمان تشغيل الادارات العامه في
الاساس بذلك ترتفع قيمه تمويلات البنك
الدولي اوكرانيا الى 18 مليار دولار على
شكل قرودا وهبه منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
علما انه تم حتى الان صرف 15 مليارا منها